il collo premessa prima di cominciare
ragazzi non ho detto però tutti ragazzi
tranquilli lo dico dopo perché sono la
gente si suicida in questo video di
geometri da ciò fatto praticamente dei
livelli e che sono i più difficili in
assoluto di geometri das quindi non ne
ho finito manco uno però li ho provati
un po tutti per riuscire a vedere fin
dove arrivano quindi è normale cioè non
ti iscrivetevi ti può fare prima perché
ero finirci livelli porca [ __ ] siate
buoni ci ho provato sono una persona
essere umano questi livelli sono fatti
per gli alieni che hanno 6 braccia i
ragazzi mi lascio al video la bella
tutti ragazzi avete costruito troppo i
getti siamo su geometrie dati che è
bello farlo entro mio dio un pappagallo
ci sarà tipo una volta che inizia
geometri dai senza che passi la savana
di di sfondo ragazzi voglio provare a
fare livelli quelli per che ballerà ogni
volta che faccio un livello impossibile
che io trovo impossibile
molti di voi mi dicono farvi ma in
realtà è vero non è difficile provo a
fare a [ __ ] ci voglio provare per lei
stessa puntata qua voglio provare a fare
lo schifo questo kleiter funk non ridete
farcire ho fatto 2 per cento ed è un
record non mi ricordo neanche quale è ma
va bene non mi ricordo proprio record
[Musica]
ragazzi non so neanche io cosa ho fatto
ma va bene parte che la musica è troppo
figlia qualcos'altro non so se riuscirò
a finirne manco uno di questi ma cercate
di capirmi sono un essere umano si prova
in tutti i modi possibili perché una
donna che pro e va beh stiamo arrivando
a un 10 per cento che per me è già buono
ragazzi mi accontento [ __ ] ok ok
madonna che prova a caso a caso o mio
dio a caso no vabbè troppa pregi in un
colpo solo rega troppa roba non riuscirò
mai più nella vita che è ok guardalo
madonna basta ragazzi fare qui qualcuno
mi deve spiegare perché cosa devo fare
qua ragazza e che cazzo ne so io ok a
caso a chiama [ __ ] ok
rinvii o devo saltare cazzo non potevo
decidere di farla domani sta cosa dei
livelli impossibili proprio oggi dovevo
farlo di calmino
guarda lo guarda lo guardano madonna
madonna le cose ha chiamato impedimento
più piccolo a caso non l'ho capita sta
cosa però arriverà 22 per cento dovuto
distruggermi il dito distruggere il
mouse e donare un rene e stato gia
difficile no veramente regard
ma dopo questo basta geometri non ne
posso più ok pian piano tranquilli non
soffiare il naso un problema questo è la
madonna la madonna è la madonna guardalo
ragazzi ci siamo ci siamo stato sono
raffreddato come un cane e devo giocare
a sta roba che miss inizio la gola
guarda che schifo ma perché perché
madonna madonna no doverosa è quello
sapere è lo sapevo se mio dio mio dio è
vabbè ma certo oddio che cos'è sta roba
ho visto una moneta ma mica l'ho vista
per un secondo è andata via subito 40
per cento
cosa cazzo fatto che non so neanche che
cosa ho cliccato basta basta ok ok no
vabbè l'ultima basta è una roba
allucinante ma di quelle proprio che
devi avere 14 braccia comunque ragazzi
clutter funk 40 per cento va bene così
tristissimo fare sta roba teorie febbre
film primo a fare questo the big 20 ore
proprio
che cazzo è bello ma che poi più ha
davanti più e pauroso nel senso che
dovrebbe essere più porca [ __ ] più
difficile no perché è piaciuto farlo
apposta si tratta niente
ok bravo o cazzo cioè ragazzi può fare a
chiasso sto livello è possibile ma che
poi bisogna arrivare a 100 per cento in
non so neanche chi li ha fatti i livelli
con il bello ok no cazzo era arrivato la
supposta voglio arrivarci almeno a
quella poi mollo tutto e vado alle
hawaii
finalmente quattro ore e mezza presso
schifo qualcos'altro di sottopasso amica
di sotto riesco dove vado
per quante strade ci sono ok ok ok
ciò fa sì che lo diventerà di infilare
sta cazzo di supposto dico io guarda chi
la nostra gara nei prossimi si si si
vi ringrazio però non ho fatto in tempo
a dire ti ringrazio dio che sono morto è
un problema questo grosso anche 9 grazie
è stato bello ciao prossima e l'ex
manager
oggi siamo così proviamo di un po tutti
perché se non facciamo un cazzo
6 per cento al caldo da la musica è
bellissima comunque a parte questo sisma
in discoteca a parte tutto qualche arma
8 per cento da questa è fattibile ok ok
ok ok ok guarda sempre quello salto e
vai vai forza forza gianfrà forza un
cazzo leone dai e l'ho preso e stato un
miracolo però va bene quindi ci faccia
così raggiunto la percentuale di quello
di prima in tre tentativi 4 11 mo so
contare che abbia aperto il conto quando
gioca star o mio dio che musica di merda
vabbè non scherzo
[Musica]
vi sembra possibile che io stia facendo
così tanto non lo so neanche io perché
dopo 31 a ciascun caso è successo reja
comunque agazzi ha fatti a tutto sono
messo gioca da un certo punto in poi va
a culo perché non lo salto sempre sempre
stavo dicendo che a un certo tipo di
ecco adesso cosa sto cliccando non lo so
manco io l'ho fatta a caso 34 cazzo c'è
un che incredibile di obeh va bene va
bene così mi accontento 38 per cento al
38 19 questo è traumatico a parte st
kucka elettrodinamici su 11 ancora
successo electron in al problema elettro
dinamismi corda ha già adesso ma ricordo
purtroppo a casa la prima parte l'ho
fatta
questa mi sa di no ok va bene c'è una
roba allucinante home io dissi la musica
spacca però regalo bellissimo livello fa
cagare per la musica bella e non
non so neanche dove sono morto con il
problema non è che posso correggere il
miur e dove cazzo dovrei andare come
cazzo faccia fast a parma bar [ __ ] a
vedere non vedo neanche dove si si si si
ragazzi ma adesso lo finisco era un po
esagerato però ragazzi sono
contentissimo così basta e vado a farmi
una torta adesso riesco a caso prima non
ci sono adesso riesco sempre ma
veramente ma veramente costa cosma dove
va bè ragazzi basta 22 ok provo l'ultimo
e poi è nuova non ebbe questo è troppo
facile perché c'è la faccia poco
incazzata parsi all'ultimo e poi basta
perché non ne posso ex comfort va bene
così eccolo ci si abitua la musica più
che altro basta che non sia snervante
che già manca solo quello non ho mai
giocato mi caccia fatto quando le per
cento più fantasma vale detto che il
fatto il record su questo livello di
battere chiunque tu sia non forse un
perfetto perfetto chiunque tu sia
fantasma che ho fatto il culo l'avevo
detto all'inizio che sarebbe stato un
anno
una merda che sarei stato un fallimento
su livelli però è normale perché tipo
dovrei non avere vita sociale che già è
poca
figurati ok ok fino amica miracolo
divino mai hai bevuto zio arriva 20 e
chiudo perché basta io in realtà sto
video è durato sei giorni solo che con i
tagli non sembra adesso adesso diventa
ubriaco
spiegami che problemi hai al cervello ma
cosa fai lilico e non va bene non clicco
è che cazzo vuoi della mia vita cui
erano anche il cavo che mi si è messo
davanti che giura lo stacco un giorno si
va bene 17 bella zip se ne vediamo alla
prossima ho provato a fargli un po tutti
tranne vabbè è stato un omaggio pazzesco
baschi io direi che posso concludere qui
la mia vita quelli di geometri da cdo
risultati già l'ultima volta spero che
mi rispondono quindi ragazzine che
possono chiudere qui sei video è
piaciuto il caso è tassato quanto mi
piace o milia ogni mi piace che mettete
una tisana che mi faccio perché devo
calmarmi ma mi ci vorranno dei mesi
estivi diavolo prossimo video belle
ragazze